-Here to perform
"Intermission Song,"
please welcome the cast of the
Tony Award-winning Best Musical,
"A Strange Loop."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ -Usher! Usher! ♪
♪ Usher! Usher! ♪
♪ How many minutes till the end
of intermission? ♪
-♪ Is that how the show should
open? ♪
-♪ Should there even
be a show? ♪
-♪ No, it should start with what
he's thinking ♪
-♪ Which is just a cursor
blinking ♪
-♪ 'Cause of all of
the directions ♪
♪ That the narrative could go ♪
-♪ He wants to show what it's
like to live up here ♪
♪ And travel the world in
a fat, black, queer body ♪
-♪ How many minutes till the end
of intermission? ♪
♪ No one cares about a writer
who is struggling to write ♪
-♪ They'll say it's way
too repetitious ♪
-♪ And so overly ambitious ♪
-♪ Which, of course,
makes them suspicious ♪
-♪ That you're trying
to be white! ♪
-♪ He has to fight for his right
to live in a world ♪
♪ That chews up and spits out ♪
♪ Black queers on the daily ♪
-♪ Blackness, queerness
fighting back ♪
♪ To fill this cis-het,
all-white space ♪
♪ With a portrait
of a portrait ♪
♪ Of a portrait of a black,
queer face ♪
♪ And a choir full of
black, queer voices ♪
♪ Treble clef ♪
-♪ And also bass ♪
-♪ That are casting spells
to conjure up ♪
-♪ A big, black and queer-ass
American Broadway ♪
-♪ Big, black and queer-ass
♪ Big, black and queer-ass
American Broadway show ♪
♪♪
♪ How many minutes till the end
of intermission? ♪
♪ Till he has to face the fact
that he is really in a jam ♪
-♪ He has no patrons
he can call on ♪
♪ Nor a backup plan to fall on ♪
-♪ Just a hamster wheel
to crawl on ♪
-♪ And nobody gives a damn ♪
-♪ He tries to scramble and
dodge and extricate ♪
♪ Still, his fate lies in wait ♪
♪ Like a scavenging vulture ♪
♪ All he wants is to subvert
expectations ♪
♪ Black and white ♪
♪ From the left and the right ♪
♪ For the good of the culture ♪
♪ Usher! Usher! ♪
♪ How many minutes till the end
of intermission? ♪
♪ You're a ball of black
confusion ♪
♪ That keeps hitting a plateau ♪
-♪ You can't just flout
every convention ♪
-♪ Then command complete
attention in a ♪
-♪ Big, black and queer-ass
American Broadway show ♪
-♪ How many minutes till the end
of intermission? ♪
♪ Some say write
from exploration ♪
♪ Some say just write
what you know ♪
-♪ But either way you keep
careening ♪
♪ So it's hard to find
a meaning in your ♪
-♪ Big, black and queer-ass
American Broadway show ♪
-♪ How many minutes till the end
of intermission? ♪
♪ If you can't please
the Caucasians ♪
♪ You will never get the dough ♪
-♪ 'Cause critics clinically
deny us ♪
♪ Then deny implicit bias ♪
-♪ With their vanity supported
by a system that's distorted ♪
-♪ Watch them write you off
as lazy ♪
♪ Not to mention navel-gazey ♪
♪ Lacking both in craft
and rigor ♪
-♪ 'Cause you're nothing but a ♪
-♪ Big, black and queer-ass ♪
-♪ Sorry about that, y'all,
sorry about that, y'all ♪
♪ Sorry about that, man ♪
-♪ Big, black and queer-ass
American Broadway ♪
♪ Big, black and queer-ass
-♪ Usher! Usher! ♪
-♪ How many minutes till ♪
♪ The end of intermission? ♪
-♪ Usher! Usher! ♪
-♪ How many minutes till the end
of intermission? ♪
-♪ Usher! Usher! ♪
-♪ How many minutes till
♪ The end of intermission? ♪
-♪ Usher! Usher! ♪
-♪ How many minutes till the end
of intermission? ♪
-♪ Usher! Usher! ♪
-♪ How many minutes till ♪
♪ The end of intermission? ♪
-♪ Oh, my God, oh, my God ♪
♪ Oh, my God ♪
♪ Oh, my God, oh, my God ♪
-♪ How many minutes till the end
of intermission? ♪
♪♪
-♪ Less than two ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Less than two.
The cast of "A Strange Loop"!
Come on now!
Fantastic!
Go see it on Broadway
at the Lyceum Theatre.
For tickets, go to
strangeloopmusical.com.